oh my gosh i had that oh my god the game
with the
paper yep
uh temple run damn
jetpack joyride no rat was like
literally
a fetus doodle jump with my [ __ ]
something that's keeping
a lot of us distracted these days is
watching tick tock but what we see on
the app and how we perceive it depends
on who we are so we invited strangers
from across the country and around the
world
to all react to the same tick tocks so
we can explore
how opposites react
i think tick tock portrays my generation
as pretty emotionally intelligent
i also think tick-tock portrays our
generation is incredibly dumb
but i like that because i think we are
very much both also we will speak
out we were very woke these days they
portray us as some
old ass grandmas and grandpas
millennials stumbled into tick-tock
try to do the dances but we're not
really good at it we drink a lot of wine
and we're like really depressed
maybe that's just my for you paige we
are the superior
generation and that's that's on facts
i think that they try to make us old
folks
look dumb yeah like like they make fun
of the way the things we say or the way
we talk
that's what i think
i need a bad bleep
addison ray will shoddy the baddest yeah
and she got her ways so these lyrics are
obviously
very heartfelt to me because i'm
absolutely
right what why is there a horse coming
out wait did i miss something hold on
who is she addison ray is she like an
influencer
so she's addison ray right and yeah
and he's making fun of her because she's
saying that was heartfelt to her and he
thinks that's silly right right
i don't even know who addison ray is
everything i know about her is from that
clip
and that's everything i need to know
the most chaotic yet amazing generation
i mean
hi can i get an orange juice please with
no ice
thank you oh pause when does orange
juice ever come with ice
[Music]
all right resume it's apple juice oh my
gosh
you know what i'm not even going to
bother you thank you guys
of course i have anxiety okay
i ain't afraid to die i ain't afraid to
die [ __ ] i've been waiting to die since
i came out the womb i ain't afraid to
die
yeah so we have anxiety but we're not
afraid of being hit by a car
like random personal interactions i feel
like could be so hard
but when it comes to stuff that like
matters we're ready we're
getting in your face i feel like
millennials are more we have more
existential dread and we're way more
pessimistic about it
gen z feels a lot of the same [ __ ] but
they're more like hopeful like i'm gonna
go in and i'm gonna
change all this
millennials when you download tick-tock
oh no that's me
what did i say wine and dancing
[ __ ] called it i don't know why but i
feel like millennials just have to make
it known
that they're able to drink like we get
it i feel like if millennials download
tik tok they're just trying to
relive their you i don't want to say
youth because most of them aren't even
that old like
30 isn't all when i was like 17 or 18 i
was always like oh my god
being 30 that would be so old but now
i'm that age i'm like wait a second
we're all the same i'm still young
anyways that's probably what people say
okay boomer why can't you
love me as
[Music]
why can't you hold me as close
as you hold your belief
that climate change isn't real
okay boomer why can't you
carry me like you carry your hand
gun in public
[Music]
i don't want to say i'm okay boomer
but boom not okay
okay okay first he gets props
great melody and lyrics he sings good
and he plays piano good yes but wait a
minute first of all i don't have a
handgun
yes second i don't put beans
well sometimes you do a couple times a
couple times
and i i believe climate change is real
i am not in that category you guys yes
yes because you're the cool boomer
thanks honey
if you describe your music taste as
oldies literally do not touch me
that's a feeling oh my god bro i hate
when people come up to me on that
pretentious ash
and they're like have you not listened
to the beatles they change music
forever bruh does it look like i give a
[ __ ] about the beatles
i've never listened to the beatles i
don't intend on it bro i'm listening to
scissors leave me the [ __ ] alone
literally me i i'll relate
i'll i'll put them on beatles every now
and again but i'll talk throw some
scissors
god how could he not like i mean it's
okay to not hit the beat like no the
beatles or anything
but listen to them man see now i feel
like a boomer now but when people are so
pretentious like oh how do you not know
this person or how you not listen to
them get out of here leave me alone
let me like what i like listen scizza
is an icon however the beatles man
come on what the [ __ ] the beatles
you need to hop on yellow submarine
god damn
so how have things been maybe i'll just
put on this earth just to die
okay like i'm not meant to find love or
be happy
i got you like i'm just supposed to die
it do be like that sometimes it do be
like that sometimes
but not all the time it'd be
like that sometimes it do be like that
sometimes
that's cute i like that i feel like with
millennials we were kind of protected in
the sense that we were just kind of
entering our teenage years when social
media became a thing and by social media
i mean like myspace and facebook but now
there's like
instant social media right and gen z is
just like
barricaded with all of this stuff all
the time and so
a lot of them are having problems
processing their feelings and they just
become evil i get that
i get that we'll be excellent therapists
our generation will be because i feel
like we talk about mental health so much
more we
are activists for mental health so
i think we'll be equipped with those
skills from an early age
is it terrifying
[ __ ] i don't even know like i can't even
tell you that
i have friends that like are getting
married now and like i'm just like i've
never had a boyfriend
and you're ready to like buy a house how
do you be
how do you be how do you be you see like
i'm more terrified to not have kids
than to have kids but not everyone is
meant to have kids
and i feel like that should be accepted
yeah man i don't know i feel like i was
way more worried about it when i was 15
you know and i think nowadays i'm just
kind of
you know going with the flow it's fine
if you don't come out like
exactly as you want it when you're 15 or
maybe you know just because there's
value in every
single outcome you can have do whatever
you gotta do if the cat is what you want
the cat is what you want
nobody should pressure you to have kids
anyways just do what you got to do and
live your extra life man
if you're not in the class get out nope
sorry i'll call security
please do because we have security right
please do
i don't need to disrupt the suit i'm not
disruptive i sat my ass down
didn't say one word and
that's the energy i wish i had in high
school she has
no chill honestly i have respect for her
though
i don't think i'd go off on a teacher
like that but i
definitely wanted to before i'm not even
gonna lie i don't know i personally do
not like people like that
like just sit down like why cause all
the disruption
i don't know what happened here's the
thing a lot of people make assumptions
from videos they see we didn't see the
beginning
maybe she is rude or maybe he's just
annoying i don't know
but ending with okay boomer she just
like threw that insult in there about
age which was not
it was not needed i wish actually there
was more of an
understanding between both sides whether
that be
gen z's millennials with boomers um
i just feel like the bridge between it
all
is communicating and understanding that
you know like we grew up in a different
time now you know i don't
think we should devalue each other
from that i think it's important to
really take a critical eye to how media
portrays each of these generations i
know this is just tik tok it's meant to
be silly and funny
lots of times if this is your only
experience how boomers act how gen z act
then of course that's how you're going
to think that all of them are so
talk to people of other generations and
see what their experience is
really like and don't get all of your
experience through media through tick
tock
and stuff like that and that's something
i feel challenged to do after
watching all of these things so i hope i
can get even better at that